[Music]
hey everyone what's up and welcome that
culture binge the wisecrack podcast
we're getting to everything going down
in the zeitgeist right now a Michael and
I'm here with wisecrack writer Alec and
wisecrack researcher surbhi how are you
guys doing today well how are you I'm
you know doing as good as anyone can be
doing right now Alec how are you doing
and feeling fine
okay stir-crazy but fine in light of the
stir craziness and the weird times I'm
curious to hear what everyone has for
chaps and slaps to get us started life
is constrained it's a little different
than normal so I'm curious to see if
that is affected
what is slapping and chopping and our
collective life so sir be would you
would you get it started get right into
it
what's laughing what's happenin your
life so instacart slaps I have been
ordering all of my groceries online and
it's been great yesterday I got in order
and it all came so that was very
exciting also I have been tipping quite
a bit so I hope we're about to ask I
think that brings you a lot of joy yeah
and that's the new threshold if you
stand between me and death you get money
so very pleased I'm happy that you're
tipping them well but I hate that that
has to be risking her life that's a
great place to be in as a society right
now where we get to weigh our tips on
the basis of how much one's put in their
life at risk and how much our own life
is that is that risk so it sounds good
but if you do use instacart normally or
is this like a special indulgence during
this time just right now during this
time I like going to the grocery store
it's very calming in a low voice I've
heard this is insane I've had multiple
people telling me that I don't
understand it at all and I don't relate
to the idea that going to the grocery
store is calming but I respect that it's
for both of you maybe it's because
everything is so organized and like it's
clean-looking and it's I don't know it
just feels really relaxing everything is
orderly and neat well there you go
so if instacart slapping what is
champing and the life of serbia this
week so I really want a puzzle and all
the puzzles are sold out I've looked on
so many websites and all the jigsaw
puzzles are sold out or the ones that
are left are super expensive all the way
all the puzzles are gone everybody's
doing puzzles servi I can send you some
really yeah I got like a weird puzzle
exchange going on with friends and I
actually think some of them are mailing
some to me but I'll get to that in a
second because this is a very weird
coincidence well so the reason why I
want to do a puzzle is that a friend of
mine is doing a puzzle call with her
friends so they work on their own
puzzles for 30 minutes every day and
they just chat and hang out and I
thought that was so fun to have a puzzle
it's exciting of the gun but my slops
for this week and do it do it I'm not
making this up is actually puzzles I'm
doing a thirty thousand piece Star Trek
puzzle the original series and it's
amazing and thank God for puzzles and
I'm sorry that you're sold out that's so
excited I will say too if anyone has
who's listening or watching has a puzzle
connect maybe get in touch with us and
you can send service and black-market
puzzles this great way Alec had you been
an active puzzler before this or is this
a self-isolation activity me and puzzles
go way back my grandfather was into them
when I was a kid and we do them but
there was like a long period of my life
where I didn't puzzle but my partner
really likes them so you know we've done
them occasionally I've gotten Rapunzel's
as gifts whatever but now it's puzzle
season because we're stuck inside all
day Wow I love that it's puzzle season
okay so so what is chapping for surbhi
is slapping for Alec but now what's
chapping for Alec is it instacart
is it no it's uh it's just people who
breed Tigers we're gonna so it's all
connected with people who breed Tigers
great I'll do mine real quick then my
chaps
I guess this kind of relates to Sir bees
in a way but what's champing for me is
the realization that right now at least
where I live food delivery is becoming
not a real option anymore and by that I
mean a lot of restaurants are closing
down for the safety of their employees
so I respect that actually today in the
New York Times there was an article or a
food writer was talking about the kind
of weird moral gray area with food
delivery right now and then in in
California and Los Angeles were on that
this week they basically told us to stay
inside and not get food or do anything
if we can help it so that's a bummer
because it has been this one little
reminder that a real world exists
outside this apartment is getting food
from other places what slaps however is
I start in the past week I got back into
using the Libbey app to download
audiobooks from the public library so
I've been doing doing book walks because
I've gotten bored of taking aimless
walks around the neighborhood on the
same paths and and and blocks so started
listening to audiobooks this week spend
fun the only bummer now is with the
whole stay inside if you can thing I'm
now paranoid to even go on my audiobook
walks so I guess that's really a chap
and a kind of slap chap but that's what
I got I haven't been doing walks but I
did go one time in the past month and I
went to an empty parking lot just like a
really big parking lot and just walked
back and forth because that's one that
looks normal to if I see someone walking
in a parking lot alone I assume this
someone has it together and who's doing
well yeah and I had like big sunglasses
and a black mask and I had my hoodie on
so obviously I looked very safe oh wow
that wouldn't raise suspicions at all
for me and I hope more of our listeners
decide to do that and then you're not
here so you're not taking walks at all
serene generally just are you staying
inside say anything you're an inside kid
yep I'm trying to do my part
Wow well that's exciting
and like I this is good I predicted our
slabs inch have to be constrained by the
constraints and limitations on our lives
and they work so we have a lot to talk
about today we're going to get into code
nineteen conspiracies we're gonna talk
about the peace corpse and ask are the
peace corpse really that peaceful but to
get started and to touch on what is
champion and Alex life we're gonna talk
about tiger King I think it's just hard
to say that we are a podcast that deals
what's with what's going on in the
zeitgeist and not talk about Tiger King
right now I think it's been the most
talked about cultural artifact over the
past few weeks and for some reason it
seems like it's become the perfect self
isolation quarantine entertainment now
let me ask you all before I get into its
Serbian Alec have we seen Tiger King and
how much have we seen I watched it I
hated every second of it okay well we'll
get into this but you've seen the whole
thing Alec have you seen the whole thing
I've seen the whole thing okay
so for anyone who's watching or
listening to this who hasn't seen it and
I'm gonna imagine if there's one thing
most people have seen it's this it is
the story of a failed independent
candidate for president from Oklahoma
named Joe exotic and along with his
presidential run
he runs a we won't say makeshift but he
runs his own zoo that features lots of
tigers and cats including other animals
he gets into a beef with a woman named
Carol Baskin who maybe are definitely
killed her husband and he was based out
of Tampa who runs a cat sanctuary
we have side characters like Bhagavan
who is a weird cult leader who grooms
women to work at his Tiger rescue in
South Carolina in charge of people $300
to pet them we get a guy named Jeff Lowe
who's this sleazy criminal that's a very
bad guy and wears do-rags and hats every
day even though he's like a 55 year old
bald minh a lot of other stuff happens
along the way but the main gist of the
story is there are two people Joe and
Carol that both run tiger zoos or
sanctuaries that both think of the other
as the enemy and one of the gist of the
story and I guest like I can spoil it
right or should I not
canopy's more lofts if anyone doesn't
want to spoil earmuffs it but i honestly
think this doesn't change anything
because there's so many twists that it
would be impossible for us to really
spoil it but one of the main narrative
arcs of the documentary series is that
this guy Joe exotic puts a hit out on
his enemy in the tiger trade Carol
Baskin because her organization is sort
of attacking his giving him bad press
trying to turn PETA and other animal
organizations against him because of
this Joe exotic ends up in jail and I'll
just say right now Joe exotic currently
has kovat 19 in jail yes yeah so this
really it really touches on everything
now the wildest thing about this is I
think I started watching this the second
week it was out after I just saw so many
people on social media talking about the
tiger king over and over and over and
you know me my partner started watching
it were a little bit appalled but got
very caught up in it and it was very
entertaining I think the week we watched
it was maybe like a week and a half into
largely being self isolated now I've
really liked it when I first watched it
now with a week or two removed I feel
bad that I liked it and it kind of
brings up this question of why is it so
entertaining and why do we like stuff
like this because there are no good guys
or no good people in tiger King every
character to a certain extent is bad you
have various forms of abuse to both
humans and animals
we have attempts at murder and maybe
successful murders we have one person
who's running a sex cult which seems to
be grooming women to be a sort of harem
we have people who seem to have clear
emotional and mental disorders who are
not being taken care of and are being
abused we have the main character Joe
exotic the tiger king who both grooms
young men with meth and then convinces
them to get married to him in a
polyamorous throuple I think that's what
one calls it yeah you know I know things
and there's no real clear resolution to
this story other than one person ends up
in jail
but by the end it's it's pretty dark yet
it was very compelling and one thing I
was thinking of this in comparison to
was making a murderer another Netflix
series that I feel like came out
everyone started watching it but making
a murderer while it touches on some dark
things and maybe some messed up people
was asking some fundamental questions
about the nature of the criminal justice
system and I think the underlying theme
in making a murderer is that there are
whether or not we think this guy did it
or not that there's serious issues and
criminal justice in this country we all
need to think about
I don't think Tiger King really gets at
issues of animal abuse and laws around
that in any meaningful way I think
that's all kind of in the background the
story largely has to do with these
insane people and the insane things they
get into and it's a weird sort of
entertainment in that it's hard to watch
this without at various points
sympathizing with people in it and I
even remember like two episodes in
thinking that Bhagavan was kind of cool
and then right when I was like I said a
lot of my partner I was like oh this guy
kind of rips and then like two seconds
later it was like oh yeah and he's like
a piece of [ __ ] that runs a sex cult and
you know shoots Tigers and buries them
in his backyard and he rides an elephant
around the neighborhood at any point in
this you think you might sympathize for
someone it turns and you immediately
feel really bad so let me ask you each
two questions
what was your experience and watching
Tiger King both as you were watching it
and as you've had time to process it and
and what do you think this says about us
that as a culture we've largely been
obsessed with this show for the past
three weeks all right to speak too so
when I watched it I really liked the
first two episodes and then it kind of
gets more true cry me about you know
this hit for hire
where did Carroll Baskins husband go and
that's when I started kind of disliking
not I wouldn't even say just like I just
like that whatever but to your point I
think like this story could have easily
played out and the guy who makes
documentary who's in it is like a turtle
conservationist and I think the
craziness of Joe exotic and
dah can tell and all these people could
have actually like put in some like good
framing of actual kind of debates and
questions about conservation right
because I think what ends up happening
is like it frames first of all all you
hear about the criticisms are from
people who hate each other right so when
Joe exotic is criticizing the way that
Carol Baskin raises Tigers like like Joe
exotic will say anything to sort of get
back at her and you know he'll say that
da can tell runs gas chambers for the
big cats and and whatever and you know
vice versa
Carol basket also hates these people and
there's never a moment where they like
actually talk to a person who's maybe a
little attached and says like oh here's
sort of like the debate or interesting
question because you know this comes up
in just non-profit zoos or conservation
in general in that there's a lot of very
good criticism of zoos keeping you know
animals in cages it's bad for them
whatever on the other end it's hard to
deny that you know someone coming like
seeing a tiger will make them care more
about it which is a sort of message that
Joe xotic has now the problem is he's
not very believable because he's just
making what I imagine is millions of
dollars off of people petting tiger cubs
and all that [ __ ] and so you know I
don't I don't know the answer to these
questions I'm very skeptical zoos in
general but it would have been nice to
hear like a smart framing of like actual
conservation people who are detached
from the bickering of these weird people
and so I was disappointed in that sense
and sorry what was your second oh the
second question and this is maybe the
one where I'm asking you all to sort of
speculate sociologically why are we all
so obsessed with us why do we like this
so much and why do we like things like
this so much oh well I think I think Joe
exotic is a very good kind of tragic
hero at least like in the Greek sense in
that it does a very good job the
documentary of setting him up and even
in the final scenes that they do this
he's kind of this person who truly
really does care about Tigers at least
at first and then has this fatal flaw
which is his narcissism or has sort of
greed and then his life unravels as a
result of it this is
what happens with every sort of kind of
tragic Greek figure you know in lots of
stories and stuff like that and so it's
hard when at the end they show Joe
exotic criticizing people who breed
Tigers and how he's kind of strayed so
far from that but now he's getting his
comeuppance in prison and he's so
distraught it's hard not to I'm not
saying he doesn't deserve to be in
prison but it's hard not to sort of want
him to learn his lesson or gets her
Redemption and also I think just in
general the world is so very complicated
and crazy and it helps to have a very
easy villain whether it's Billy
McFarland and fire fast more Joe exotic
and Tigers you know yeah
sir B same questions at you what did you
think and what does it say about us well
I really appreciate everything that Alok
just said and I agree with with a lot of
it I had a very difficult time watching
this series and it was playing in the
background and I remember when I
finished the first episode I was so
stressed out and upset and I couldn't
figure out like why I was so tense the
rest of the day and it was because of
this documentary I hated the animal
abuse and cruelty and I just I can't
sympathize with him at all
I think he's just the worst person I
think everybody in that show is terrible
and the the fact that Netflix didn't ask
important questions it was almost as if
like here's like a train wreck of a show
enjoy and there was no substance beyond
that I think I found out like just very
disheartening because there was no like
good or bad there was no moment where I
thought like well is it good that he's
breeding Tigers because we don't have
that many in the wild or is there a way
we can learn from him there was nothing
like that it was just mmm he's a meth
addict and he abuses animals and asks
for why it's so popular I think that
people have a strong
need to belong and they'll jump on any
bandwagon they can and if this is the
new trend for people to be supporting
Joe exotic and saying I I read somewhere
that somebody some celebrity was going
to create a GoFundMe page to get him
Audrey yeah and like I think the
Kardashians were gonna do something I I
heard something that like Kim and Kanye
wanted to use their their criminal
justice prowess to free him so yeah like
things like that like I just I don't
know if they think it's funny or if they
truly believe it but I think that people
just really want to feel a sense of
belonging and if this is the new thing
that everybody's talking about they want
to feel relevant and a part of the
conversation but I think that can have
significant negative effects on our
perceptions of what's right and wrong
like everybody's talking about how he's
such a great character he's funny or
what a wild story that when about the
fact that he under feeds these Tigers
and that he kills them and that he takes
them away from their moms that like
three days old or an hour old he took
them away and was letting people pet
them so nobody's focusing on like the
animal abuse and that I find very
upsetting especially from Netflix I feel
like it could have been a more
interesting series had they focused on
something more than this trash human
well do you all think that if we were
not or if most people in the Western
world weren't currently some level of
isolated or quarantined that this would
have become such a phenomena it's hard
to say I think it would have still been
popular I also think another part of the
popularity and you don't agree with a
lot of her be saying is just the fact
that big cats are awesome and they're
not fun to look at and yeah half of it
having me watching this documentaries
like I really want to pet that tiger
I would not actually go and pay for it
that is bad and wrong but I really want
to yeah well maybe one of the positives
here is if people watch that and like
Alex that their takeaway was big cats
are pretty impressive
I mean maybe go watch play
instead or one of the delightful nature
documentaries or anything made by David
Attenborough where you can just see
Tigers in the wild not being abused I
mean one very minor moral question that
comes up in this because at one point
and I forget the actual number but they
bring up that there's more Tigers in
captivity right now than there are in
the wild and I think you know maybe
there's some some logic here I'm missing
but it's hard to not think for a second
well like in a very utilitarian way
almost I guess it's better that there's
this many Tigers than no Tigers if they
were breeding them this is probably
impossible because they would be
socialized but if they were breeding
them making some money and then like
releasing them in the wild successfully
I'd be like ok I still feel weird
cropping off animals like this but
they're but you know I think first of
all if you breed them long enough they
will become domesticated and no longer
wild right lots of species and I don't
really know the timeline of that but
what happens which is exactly what
happened with like horses dogs and cats
and lots of other animals is that when
they're in close contact with humans the
ones that are often like successful in
breeding or you know don't get put down
earlier are the ones that are super nice
and calm and so you end up with animals
that don't attack you generation after
generation and at that point you're
creating like a new breed of pet and not
a tiger you know yeah makes me think of
did either of you all see the
documentary sea of shadows they came out
I think late 2019 so it's about the toe
- wobba fish the vaquita and the toe toe
- all the fish in Mexico and it's a fish
the people are obsessed with so people
are long story short people are hunting
is one fish because it's a bladder has
some sort of like narcotic effect and
they like it in food and in like Taiwan
or something but there's a fish that
gets killed in the process it's going to
stink to Mexico this one group conserves
the fish they try to release the fish
back into the wild and they try to
release it into the wild that doesn't
know what to do and it eventually kills
itself it's very dark
spoiler alert and that
but it gets it the question of you know
how how much can we take something out
of its natural environment and ever
reintroduce it and at a certain point
like Alec just brought up does
conservation kind of work against itself
in that way and I guess it's hard yeah
to not think about that when watching
something like this because you you
wonder can't Joe and Carol just take all
their tigers and put them in the wild
but like what does that mean practically
and they probably would all get killed
within days I also think they've missed
some easy questions about like ethical
questions around pets right like we can
look at Joe and be like he's taking the
tiger cubs from their parents but pet
breeders do this all the time you know
you know they talk about you know Tigers
need lots of square miles to sort of
successfully live but I've always
wondered like I've adopted an old cat I
love cats but like is if I were getting
a younger cat would my small New York
City apartment be like in a healthy
environment for it and like we just
don't ask those questions but I feel
like there's a lot of overlap and just
even watching the Tigers and how they do
the exact same weird [ __ ] that cats do
like you know rub their face on cages
and you know kind of sit over there pray
exactly how my cat it just I don't know
it made me wonder about certain things
definitely to go back to your earlier
question about whether this would have
been popular had we not been in
self-isolation I don't think it would
have reached this level of popularity do
either of you remember during the 9/11
attacks there was that movie that came
out by Mariah Carey and it was a total
way really no but it was something like
a G Li litter story glitter yes I've
heard about and it like knocked it out
of the park like at the box office I
think they did so well and people said
that it did well because in such a
stressful time people wanted an escape
and it didn't matter what it was they
wanted something to take their mind off
of the current events that they were
dealing with so I wonder if that's
something similar right now that we need
our minds to have a rest and to not
think about the pandemic and death and
family and loved ones so it's easier to
watch
the tiger King than it is to think about
kovat 19 should we all yeah so we're
we're gonna wait till the end but we're
announcing the culture binge movie watch
club we're starting with glitter we'll
give you details at the end no but I
think you're right that like during
times like this sensationalism helps and
I know that in my household at least my
partner and I who never watch reality TV
I'm gonna say which one had been binging
a reality TV show because it feels like
that pure sensationalist escape um and
we need to move on if you have so much
good stuff to talk about but final
question here at what point in the
series did you all realize that Joe
exotics country music was all
lip-synched because he didn't make it
wait he I was like his singing is
weirdly competent so yeah it's cuz it's
not lip-synching in the music video
because that's what everyone does but he
doesn't yeah that is not Joe exotics
voice there is a duo in Washington state
that writes all the music for him you
know his classic songs like here kitty
kitty
but yeah III I'll say this I was very
I'm proud of myself within ten seconds
of the first music video it's like
that's not him I know it's not high I'm
not a fan of country music but I was
like hey this is actually isn't that bad
I like to meet oh those are good yeah I
was like I don't know but I think it
would if you told me that that was a
popular country song without saying who
made up okay sure and that's why now my
favorite part of the show looking back
is one clip where they're kind of
interviewing him in a casual setting
he's like yeah the music for me that's
just my escape that's where I go to just
really express myself and it's like
mother that's not you cool well that's
that anyone once again if you've watched
out your King we want to hear from you
later so you can tell us what you
thought about it if you haven't watched
it I don't know maybe don't I'll say
that if you have not watched it at this
point maybe find something better to
watch but speaking of things that
unequivocally help the world and are
good and that there's nothing bad to say
about Serbia what's up with the Peace
Corps Peace Corps so many things to talk
about so the Peace Corps is a volunteer
program run by the US government so for
those of you who don't know these
volunteers work in developing countries
for about two years and they help local
community
with anything from health and education
to agriculture and environment and
economic development and I've always
been interested in the Peace Corps when
I graduated from college there was a
very very brief moment when I thought
about joining and then I realized that I
would be horrible at that experience so
I came to my senses but I've always been
very interested so I recently came
across an article published in The New
Yorker last month about the program's
connection with China this year the
Peace Corps abruptly ended the program
in China saying that the country had
developed so much that it was graduating
from the Peace Corps others say that the
program ended because of political
reasons I say that we don't focus on
China at all and rather discuss whether
the Peace Corps is helpful or
detrimental to local communities so
before we jump in I have a few facts to
share so one is that there is very
little quantitative evidence that the
Peace Corps has a positive development
impact on local communities and two it
costs us us taxpayers about $50,000 per
volunteer per year and there are roughly
7,000 volunteers each year so that's
about 350 million dollars a year that we
spend on the Peace Corps so opponents of
the Peace Corps alleged that the program
is a form of American exceptionalism
which is the concept that the US is
superior to other nations and that
Americans have a unique mission to
transform the world furthermore the idea
of white white Savior ISM or Western
Savior ISM is also important in this
discussion since it refers to people
visiting struggling nations in order to
fix their problems without having a full
appreciation of their culture in history
proponents say that the Peace Corps
volunteers help empower local
communities for example individuals can
work on specific projects they can help
farmers increase food security they can
teach computer skills to local
businesses to
helped them connect with the global
marketplace they can work in hiv/aids
education to educate local communities
about sexual health so before I tell you
what I think I'd love to know what the
two of you think or if either of you
have known people who have been Peace
Corps volunteers what are your thoughts
I haven't known anyone who's done it
recently I read Jia Tolentino The New
Yorker writer put out a book called
trickier and she writes about her
experience in the Peace Corps and it
sounds not good and she in particular
talks about how as a woman in the Peace
Corps she had to deal with a lot of like
a sexual harassment and even if you go
to the Wikipedia page for the Peace
Corps there's an entire section on
sexual assault and harassment because
there's such a rampant history of that
particular with the women who join it I
for a while and I guess this isn't true
but for years I someone told me once it
was a front for the CIA and that's how
it started so I of course just believed
that uncritically maybe that's true I
don't know but I could add a quick
caveat i I don't know about the CIA
claim but I know a lot of United States
humanitarian efforts across the world
especially during the Cold War were
mostly framed as like propaganda efforts
and so this isn't the peace corps this
is different but like we went the United
States so I tried to eradicate malaria
around the world then we were involved
in smallpox and also polio and the
reason they would write the checks and
like we honest-to-god were trying to do
these things but the reason they were
writing the checks is because everyone
was so mad at us during the Vietnam War
globally were like hey maybe if we make
you die less from malaria you won't hate
us as much and so that's one specific
example but a lot of the things we do
are framed strategically like that like
we're gonna give you know a to this
country because we want to sort of make
them more prone so that they don't like
have a socialist revolution or so they
don't become an ally of the USSR yeah
and so you know the Peace Corps was
founded I think under Kennedy mmm-hmm
and I've never seen or vetted claims
that they were involved with the CIA but
I think the mission is still
same of yeah we're gonna help people but
we're really helping people to shore up
support for America and it's like
military operations abroad yeah and I
mean it's hard to imagine something with
the Peace Corps not having an explicit
or implicit ideological function kind of
along with what you were saying there
Alec and it also just makes me think for
America to have a Peace Corps it'd be
like if like Charlie Sheen ran a
sobriety core or something like that
like I just don't know if globally if
you look at America and think like this
is the country that's gonna teach us
about peace and prosperity and fighting
inequality because this is gonna be a
shock to many but we have quite a few
problems of our own
on our shores so I think there's often
than that criticism as well of you know
what are we doing domestically I know
they have like a program is that like
City year or something like that which
is a sort of domestic counterpart or no
AmeriCorps I'm sorry I mean Teach for
America which is also as oh yeah oh and
you know you asked this before about um
if any of us had done it or been a part
of it I was actually a part of
AmeriCorps for a year so I guess I have
been associated with it and all I'll say
is it was it was bad and not good in
many ways and felt like a way to I guess
create government oversight and control
for nonprofits by giving them employees
and volunteers and interns that were on
AmeriCorps contracts that then meant you
had to do things a certain way so in
terms of what Alec was saying with the
kind of like ideological and cultural
and political influence of the Peace
Corps overseas I know the nonprofit I
was working at under an AmeriCorps grant
it was kind of like that like it
constrain what I was allowed to do and
work on because it had to be in
alignment with their values is there
anything the image that comes to mind
again not about the Peace Corps but like
just humanitarian efforts in let's say
like Africa is they think they
understand the problem and they have
like a solution that is just so far from
like the reality of what's happening
like building certain things that like
but not like teaching the people who
live there how to use them so they
immediately break and nothing
like is is that in the article that
you're reading so that's been in some of
the research that I found yeah that they
come in and they have these ideas of
what African nations need so they get
there and they start to implement their
projects only to find out that the
community is not interested in those
things they'll either say we don't need
that we already get food aid from this
other community what we need is this or
they'll say that there's so much lack
there's a lack of support and structure
from the Peace Corps that it's up to the
volunteer to figure out their program or
mean their project so I spoke to one
former volunteer who was in South
America and she said that it took about
a year for her to get support from the
local community to actually do her
project and then by the time she got it
going she's like I had to leave in like
nine months and just fell so for like a
year she didn't do anything I mean she
she tried to do things but she wasn't
making she was an effecting change or
doing what she wanted to do so it seems
like we have these ideas of what we
think countries need and what local
communities need and we go there and we
start to impose our solutions on them
without really understanding what that
community needs and I mean and and I
haven't joined the Peace Corps so if
there is a Peace Corps volunteer out
there and I'm getting everything wrong
please write in to set me straight but I
do think there's a real problem with the
Peace Corps because it has the potential
to diminish a community sensitive agency
and they could come to rely on these
volunteers or maybe see these
individuals as experts and rely less on
their own ingenuity to create solutions
and solve problems in order in favor of
the opinions of others and I also don't
like that there's lack of support and
structure from the Peace Corps like
you're just sort of on your own once you
get into the community so who do you
turn to if you need help or advice or
anything like
that there's nothing there's nothing to
help support the volunteers once they're
there and I think that three hundred and
fifty million dollars could be better
spent elsewhere or maybe in a more
impactful way in a more structured way I
don't think yeah of course really what
we need well yeah and everything you're
saying really makes me think as well as
some of the problems with like certain
sorts of religious missionary work and
overseas ministry stuff because one of
the biggest issues you get in those
context are people doing projects that
they think people need or want
projecting their cultural values and a
lack of I guess what we could call like
cultural anthropological research or
sort of ethnography on those places what
they need what they need to do and you
know people that do like ethnographic
research often have to spend tons of
time in communities just to get to the
point where they can begin to start
understanding things being accepted so
like you said just to plop down there
like that maybe not the best I mean do
you think and this is this is asking a
big question is there it can either of
you imagine like an alternative to this
a way that a nation could have a
volunteer program like this that didn't
suck yeah I think the difference is this
is gonna use like a military analogy but
I think it's similar like I think
there's a difference between saying
you're fighting a war and we're gonna
like drop our entire military there and
I kind of take over versus sending
volunteers so like during World War two
we would send pilots to you know the UK
who would you know serve under the
British Army fly their planes etc etc
and so like they're just getting sort of
more bodies to help them similarly like
on global intervention one model is like
again we're gonna fix the problem the
other is like we're gonna work with like
the existing sort of infrastructure and
I think on the volunteer level it's the
same thing right like what are the
health organizations that are locally
run should you go there like is there a
way I even met at VidCon last year and I
don't really know much about what he's
doing so I don't think it was an evil
horrible front but he was a dentist but
his YouTube channel is all about
traveling the world and he was able to
travel to like almost every country or
every country on earth because he would
just contact
like local governments or like denture
groups being like hey do you need a
volunteer dentist for you know three
months four months six months a year or
whatever but again like not setting up
his weird dentistry organization run he
would just probably show up at whatever
infrastructure they had and start
cleaning people's teeth and removing
cavities and stuff like that and I think
that's probably the best model granted I
think there are probably some cases
where if the infrastructure doesn't
exist again this happens in public
health a lot like we'll help you out but
I don't know it gets super tricky yeah
that guy's dentistry thing kind of
sounds like a Doctors Without Borders
thing who for the most part seems like a
solid group maybe I think maybe send us
yeah yeah what is now I do agree that
connecting with local organizations like
NGOs would be really great I went to
school went to college with a girl who
is a nurse so she moved to Africa and
worked at a at a OB GYN clinic and she
helped deliver babies so and one of the
things that she did was she helped
design these like foam thing like these
foam tools to help like prop up the
women's bodies to help make delivery
easier so I think that is a small thing
that can have a big impact because a lot
of these women were in labor for like 50
hours and she was able to cut that down
so I think that's like a small thing
that has a big impact and can save lives
I also like the idea of Doctors Without
Borders I don't know if it's actually
good or not so somebody has experience
with that please let us know the other
thing that comes to mind is Japan's
English teaching program that's like
supported and organized by the Japanese
government where it's like super hard to
get into I think it's like a very
competitive process and it's very
structured from what I understand that
they like send you to rural villages so
you teach English so I don't know if
it's good or not but I liked the idea of
that maybe that could be useful I think
the last thing
that I want to bring up is uh there's
this great video this is not an
international thing buts the same sort
of logic I'm gonna help but make things
way worse real engineering is a YouTube
channel put out this great video on
ventilators everyone's like we're gonna
build these low-cost ventilators and he
goes through how they're made and how
they will kill lots of people because
they don't understand how ventilators
actually work that hospitals need what
happens is if you put too much air and
air pressure into the lungs you will
erect probably damage them and kill
people and essentially people are just
designing all these like plastic bags
will air to like shove air down their
throats and that's not how like real
ventilators measure the air pressure
they're finely tuned they like have some
mechanism to make sure that doesn't
happen it's great video real engineering
but again it's that logic of I know the
solution when you don't at all another
solution I think it's amplified when
you're dealing with like cultures you
don't understand
yeah don't build your own ventilator and
I and I do feel like you know the point
Survey's bringing up which we can end on
is no one should try to help it's not
worth it
that's all in vain never do anything
because you'll end up screwing it up no
but it don't do not under any
circumstances tip no but if it
especially do of anyone has experienced
that I'm sure we'd love to hear about it
any final thoughts sir be before we move
on no please write in if you have
experience with Peace Corps I would love
to hear from you yeah and if you're
there now and you're under some weird
contract you can use the anonymous name
will respect it we will not snitch
that's a policy at this point is no
snitching they almost come home because
of Cove in nineteen know Peace Corps
volunteers anyway oh okay well speaking
of Cove in nineteen a liqu we know that
you are our in-house expert on all types
of health related conspiracies it's it's
sort of like you're your pet project
you're awake at night reading books
about anti-vaxxers and stuff what do you
have to share with us about the wide
world of Koba 19 conspiracy theories I
think I found my new favorite conspiracy
and its really competing with Flat Earth
so we'll see but every time I think I've
sort of wrapped up neatly my
understanding of the conspiracy and what
they're saying
it just has like a new twist
turn that it's just amazing so the
conspiracy theory is and fYI these I'll
get to this but these theories are wrong
and I can explain that
but that 5g the the nice fast internet
service is causing kovat nineteen
coronavirus whatever you want to call it
I'm not sure where the claim originated
but specifically I watch this video that
has since been taken down but what was
that like six hundred thousand views by
this guy named Thomas Cowan who you know
makes the claim in this 10-minute video
but this basic idea has been spread by
celebrities like Woody Harrelson who
wasn't like I believe this boys oh no he
was like I should I should check this
out like some friends have been sending
this to me some singer I'd never heard
of people in England are burning
cellphone towers some of which don't
even provide 5g service they're just
regular 4G and it's suspected it's
because of these conspiracy theories
people are also selling anti 5g thumb
drives have no idea how that works that
was the thing I learned this morning but
I really want to know what they're
claiming but anyway this video by this
guy Thomas count at 600,000 views I'm
not sure if he originated the theory I
think anti 5ge stuff predated this but
the video and I'm sorry that you all
can't watch this it was it was amazing
by just the [ __ ] he was saying in ten
minutes
he makes manages to make a series of
claims including viruses are not
infectious microbes as we understand
them I'm gonna call this virus denialism
it's not that viruses don't exist but he
thinks they are the toxic byproduct of
cells cleansing themselves so like your
cells like here's a bit of DNA that I
want to expel and I'm gonna put it out
there and as part of this theory he
thinks that all or most modern pandemics
of the you know since the 1900s have
been caused by like the electrification
of the earth including the Spanish flu
which I believe killed millions of
people he claims it is not infectious he
cites some bizarre anecdote that I
couldn't find the actual source of that
the Boston Health Department took snot
out of people's noses and inject it into
people and could not cause flu and other
people so again like the Spanish flu was
caused by
radio waves by the way there have been
countless studies where people take like
sorry they take the viral material snot
or just virus cells sorry the the viral
material and inject it into monkeys
humans whatever and it causes the flu
that's how [ __ ] viruses work so again
that is not true the best part is this
guy is a medical doctor not only is he a
medical doctor he has a practice in San
Francisco he is on probation so there
was a decision from the California
Medical Board that kind of revoked his
license but then stayed the revocation
so he's on probation for five years
because and here's what he did there was
a cancer patient a person with
metastatic breast cancer who I read the
whole complaint this is how [ __ ] deep
I have into this a person with
metastatic breast cancer calls him is
like what should I do
he's like seen oncologist says thank you
Thomas for encouraging as people see an
oncologist but also take this drug this
drug has never been fda-approved there
has never even been safety trials for it
and actually I think like since then
there might be phase one which are
animal trials for some unrelated
condition but the manufacturer had to
stop making it because it was dangerous
and the manufacturer after like six
months or something like that it was
like hey we can't sell this to you
anymore it's dangerous at which point
she calls Thomas cow and it's like what
the [ __ ] what is this drug that I'm
taking and what Gaudin was not only did
he tell a patient to take an unlicensed
untested drug that we don't know is safe
or not he did not perform a physical
examination which is pretty important he
didn't even look at her medical records
like you know anytime you prescribe
anyone anything you'd be like Oh am i
prescribing you something that might
kill you based on something else also
did not record any of the information
from any two phone calls so he's barred
from treating cancer patients and this
was in 2017 hours from treating all
patient yeah III think so too and
actually I'm trying to figure out I
actually looked at as I was watching his
videos if I could like that cuz you can
send a complaint about a doctor but it
seemed like the criteria for
sending them him saying dumb [ __ ] on
YouTube videos was not in there but if
I'm wrong please let me know I have lots
of things I'd like to send I have there
she's talented but anyway so I do have
even deeper into this heat this guy has
an hour and a half long zoom like
conference call where he's explaining
all this [ __ ] it gets even better not
only does he think he points everyone to
a website that says viruses might not
exist like I I came across this idea
called germ theory denialism which is
that Louie Pasteur was wrong that like
infectious diseases or most of what we
know is infectious diseases are don't
exist and there's this famous quote
there was this rival of Pastore who was
like I believe an actual scientist it
just he had one theory of like what was
making everyone sick Pastore had
together which was germs pass or one
because he was right um but he's he had
this quote that's like germs are nothing
terrain is everything about like the
environmental influences on health and
you know there are environmental
influences on health but this is like
the cornerstone of germ theory denialism
and that quote was even mentioned by
bill maher on live television in a thing
about how vaccines are dangerous there's
a lot of overlap with anti-vaxxers here
and I would say the cherry on top is
that the guy is also an HIV denier which
is the idea that HIV virus does not
cause AIDS there's something else making
people with AIDS sick again not true but
yeah that's where we're at
yeah what do you guys think I mean I
okay so if I'm in a devil's advocate why
people would want to believe in Cova
conspiracies this is a no way defense of
the psychopaths you're talking about I
get why people like this stuff no I
don't to be clear but when something
like this happens we feel like we have
no control we feel like because we're
not experts we can't understand anything
and it's very scary but we hear some
conspiracy that gives us a secret clue
or a hint or something we can understand
now I feel like I have some control
again totally like I might have some
knowledge so I want to start by saying I
I guess at least empathize if not
sympathize with you know the motivation
for people getting into stuff like this
but it's batshit crazy and it's very
dangerous and it's scary to me in a
world where especially a lot of and I
don't want to hate on old people because
I guess to some people I'm a little
person but - like really old people a
lot of them look at the Internet as a
reliable source like evils grandparents
and stuff think like oh so-and-so is a
doctor and so-and-so is on the internet
and he's broadcasting like a TV show
he's basically like a Dan Rather vigor
and and then they say this crazy [ __ ]
and I think people can really fall for
and really make reckless decisions and
of course it's one thing when a
conspiracy leads people to believing
dumb [ __ ] on their own it's another
thing when people are burning down cell
towers especially during the time we're
being connected and using cell service
might be a little gosh darn important so
it's this is it's scary stuff and it's
scary that people like this can have
that big of a platform and then I just
always wonder with people like this do
they even believe what they're saying or
is the conspiracy theorists themselves a
sort of cult leader who's doing what
they're doing for the sake of some sort
of attention or control themselves or
are they really like the person who's
not Christ but thinks they're Christ and
wants to lead all of us to a land of
salvation I'm really torn I'm curious
what sir be thanks I've started whopper
800 it's not assumption that all these
people are sincere
including like flat-earthers I believe I
mean sure they're [ __ ] words on the
internet who are just trolling but like
Mark Sargent I think that guy believes
it and like that's not a place like he's
not making a lot of dollars off this but
yeah I think I think do you think they
believe it sir B I don't know man people
are [ __ ] we're like the more that
like I read about what other people
think about covet and just having so
much time at home to not do anything has
made me just realize that people are so
strange and this is why I self isolate
by choice all day
not even just Cove
time I don't I don't know I I think I
agree with Michael that this is a form
of control that people will believe
these things because they need an answer
I think that people who spread these
conspiracy theories or believe in these
theories have well there are two camps I
think one there could be like maybe some
mental health issues like if you really
feel this paranoid and that's your way
of thinking and the other people I think
they lack critical thinking skills which
is due to poor education or just a lack
of insight and things like that I want
to well there's two things first I don't
even think the lack of education is this
person is a medical doctor who complete
medical school although I have noticed a
thing where auto conspiracy theorists
have like advanced degrees and
especially like anti-vaxxers are
generally very well educated and like
upper class and stuff like that but I
think what it is is I actually think
medical school is the perfect example of
this because medical school isn't
necessarily about critical thinking
skills it's about like rote memorization
of like the various things that could be
killing somebody and so and this person
like in watching this is very well read
like understands the basic principles
that he's disagreeing with like it's not
that he doesn't understand he knows what
how viruses in actual science are said
to work he's just like nah that's wrong
for his variety of reasons so like he's
well-read and also is that kind of smart
where like he can memorize stuff but
like I think maybe lacks crack like
maybe it's lacking critical thinking
skills maybe it's just like the way we
teach science is like allowing these
people to sort of like glom onto like
bad and dumb ideas because I do think
like the way science is taught is just
like as a series of facts and not as
like a way to sort of approach and
understand the world which i think is
more important right like to me you know
understanding that
you know force equals mass times
acceleration I hope I got the formula
right I think that's important but I
think it's also incredibly important to
understand like how Newton formulated
that and like how people came to
understand that Newton was wrong right
and like how those things happen and so
there's that so I don't I don't think
it's that they're dumb or lack education
yeah maybe he falls in the first camp
though mental illness I don't think
that's I mean I think for some people
like especially when it gets into here's
the thing a lot of the things they
complain about our route in some kernel
of truth right like a lot of the
homeopathic and sort of doctors complain
about the way pharmaceutical companies
are greedy they complain about the way
that like doctors have a tendency to
sort of like shuffle their patients in
and out because that is sort of what's
economically necessary and those are all
like criticisms that very like
reasonable people have made about these
things but then they just take it a step
further and I think that's a lot
different and this does happen with like
sort of mental illness but like the
person will get me wrong they're a CIA
agent like that's not what I'm feeling
from these people yeah it's hard to like
but they're just so wrong yeah I know
the hard thing to and this kind of
relates something you're saying a second
ago Alec is I mean in one sense you know
I wouldn't want the flipside where we
live in a culture in which everyone
assumes that that science is sort of
unequivocally objectively right we know
that you know there's scientific
paradigm shifts in which all the
research we had before can change or
look different in the light of new
research and critical thinking so it's
as weird balance we're like I've we want
to encourage people to think critically
to not take everything as immutable fact
at the same time it's sort of like when
keeping it critical goes wrong when
people are so skeptical it becomes not a
healthy skepticism but a reckless
skepticism that leads to I I guess makes
it easier for people to believe [ __ ]
like this yeah and what I think is even
interesting is the mechanism like
figuring out that the via the novel
a virus causes the symptoms known as
kovat 19 is actually like kind of
interesting I'm not gonna get into it
all now but like some scientist has to
go in there and figure out a way to
prove that by like sequencing DNA or RNA
they put that in another cell okay it'd
have like a bad effect on another cell
and just to give a quick example this
exact thing happened with the Spanish
flu where there was one guy going around
being like the Spanish flu is caused by
a bacteria and other people are like no
no no it's caused by this other thing
way smaller than that and for a while
most people believed it was bacterial
but then they start seeing like oh
actually this bacteria is like only in
us like 30 percent of people suffering
from the Spanish flu it's in 60 percent
of people with tuberculosis and so
they're like okay well what is it and
then they sort of were able to isolate
and identify the virus and you know that
was in you know all these sick patients
and like similar things happen right
like it's not like someone just like
raises their hand be like I've
discovered the magic thing like there is
a process for discovering if a virus is
causing a specific disease and in fact
when people were getting sick from
hiv/aids at first this was the big thing
like what the [ __ ] is causing it how do
we discover it but especially during
that process and even especially now
with kovat like a lot of what we know is
like what's called like pre-publication
where there people are putting out their
findings but they have yet to be peer
reviewed and all these things and the
conspiracy theorists point to these like
see it's all [ __ ] but really it is
the scientific process to be like okay
you claim that this virus is causing
kovat but we're just gonna check we're
gonna peer review it we're gonna make
sure like you know everything works out
if I actually magically discover that's
not caused by the virus you think it is
but actually this other virus that looks
slightly different like I'm probably
gonna like everyone's gonna respect me a
lot and I'm gonna get like a great job
and possibly like the Nobel Prize for it
it's not like some conspiracy like if
somehow we're magically wrong about what
causes these symptoms and it's actually
some other virus or some other bacteria
which by the way there's no reason to
believe that currently because you know
we've done the testing but that person
would be like showered with praise hmm
well this is wildly interesting we do
need to head towards a conclusion if you
do have last thoughts on this but I
think the most important thing right is
just that everyone listening and
watching
knows like it's a scary time avoid
conspiracies like this remember that the
only known cure and prevention is to
microwave lemon juice and cayenne pepper
and drink it via your nose anything
anyone else tells you is a lie that's
the only thing you can do for sure I
thought said this before you move on
great well let's get into something that
isn't a conspiracy and that's that we
love to hear from you and by you I don't
mean Alec answer B I'm indifferent in
hearing from you but we mean the people
that watch and listen to this you're the
best you you are this podcast so hit us
up so if you want to call us you can
call us at one two one three five three
four eight eight zero seven that is one
two one three five three four eight
eight zero seven leave us a voicemail we
can hear your voice and then if you're
sarcastic we'll get it from your tone if
you're indignant we'll get that as well
you won't have to explain it in an email
with fonts um but if you do want to
leave us an email it's culture binge at
wisecrack Oh know em culture binge at
wisecrack oh and also maybe rate and
review this podcast maybe if you're
liking it right now and you're thinking
this is a good thing that I want to see
in the world and here in the world rate
it give it five stars
leave a comment and in particular you
know let us know in the comments what
career you think Alec would have been
suited for if you lived in the 19th
century I'd love to hear about that let
us know but right now do do we have some
voicemails and emails Alec that we need
to get into I believe we do in regards
to the culture bishops to talk about
isolation and also my roommate situation
voicemail I did not know how bad is
gonna get in terms of quarantine and
socialization and you want to know how
it's going it is going great we are all
talking about like how thankful we are
we all are for each other right now and
I'm also talking with my friends and
family who are just alone right now or
maybe only have like one or two other
people and they're just going insane
they don't have enough people to talk to
so I'm feeling very fortunate for the
circumstances
I'm in and just being able to I'm still
an essential worker I'm a delivery
driver so I have to go to work and then
I can come back and I can unwind talking
about the catastrophic state of the
world with all of my roommate it I
wouldn't trade it for the world and I
just wanted to give you guys that update
thank you so much for listening to me
and that my wish to know you guys all
take care for a reminder and survey
maybe refresh my memory this is Logan
who lives kind of communally with some
roommates yeah he has I forgot how many
but he has several roommates and he
called in after we talked about buying a
house with friends mm-hmm and he talked
about how much he enjoyed it how much he
loved you know coming home and having
such a big support system Wow and now
that I'm yeah
now that I'm into reality TV all I want
to know is if there's any romantic
tension in that house it's all I care
about Logan let us know we won't even
say it just let us know we won't talk
about it on air I want to know where the
tension is where there's jealousy who's
hooking up with who it's I need it in my
life that's a good update I'm glad to
hear back from I love you I'm so happy
that things are working well and I hope
you stay healthy out there I'm sorry
good no no I was saying it sounds fun to
live with all your friends at a time
like this yeah I don't know people who
live with groups of friends but I know
couples that live together and it seems
like most of the couples I know are just
arguing all the time but my theory is
that maybe arguments argument someone
all the time is bad not good but maybe
it's still better than being alone
because there's difference between being
angry and depressed and I'd rather be
angry than depressed yeah I think that's
a good call Olivia living with someone
right now and it's just the two of you
is weird it's it's intense and then go
lot of those are going through that but
yeah I probably better that than nothing
Wow
do you have any other calls or emails
okay so the email all right anyone wants
to email culture binge at wisecrack dot
Co also as a reminder leave us nice
reviews on iTunes because we read them
and they make us feel good and they help
other people discover the show but
anyway here's an email from Zach this
emails from March 30th which i think is
an important context I don't know what
state is of things where zach is but
Zach says dear culture binge crew all
the talk about social distancing and
self-quarantine is very interesting to
me because it's something I haven't
experienced personally you see I live in
a somewhat small North Alabama town and
as you might expect some people are not
taking this global pandemic seriously
the company I work for which
manufacturers rugs has done almost
nothing to deal with Cova 19 beyond a
couple of printouts on the break room
tables telling people not to come into
work if they have the coronavirus
obviously before birth but anyway
recently the Alabama governor issued a
state shut down for all non-essential
businesses and wouldn't you know what
factories were not on the list of
non-essential businesses so my options
are quit and self isolate to protect
myself but have zero income or keep
working and hope for the best and
continue to pay my bills if my job were
something actually essential that would
be one thing but nobody needs to drugs
right now unless the toilet paper runs
out stay safe and healthy Zack I'm so
sorry Zack I want an update
like what's yeah now I don't know I'm
I'm obviously in the middle of a giant
[ __ ] show New York but it feels like
things are almost maybe similar in the
rest of the country yeah I wonder it for
Zach's case if it's possible and I don't
know the the politics and policy behind
this if you can you quit a job and still
apply for this new type of unemployment
insurance I know they've expanded who
can so I would say maybe Zach like truly
if you're if you're feeling like you're
in a dangerous position that maybe
that's an option I shouldn't be given
anyone if I sign anything but I don't
know that's the thing to look into this
is serious [ __ ] and hopefully everyone
stays safe and no one you know 101 buy a
rug right now if you were thinking
you're gonna order a [ __ ] rug today
maybe don't and then help out Zach and
his friends yeah
sorry for a nice day it's okay it was
gonna be good you wanna try again
oh I was gonna say I feel like the
important thing for an essential service
is everyone's like oh my god grocery
work store workers are heroes and III
think we should give them credit where
credit is due but I think the framing is
weird because they're more like hostages
because I don't think maybe there are
some grocery store workers and applause
to these people who are like
do my civic duty and make sure people
get fed for minimum wage and I respect
those people but I feel like a lot more
of them are probably like I can't afford
to stop working and I really don't want
to like die or possibly just get sick
and end up in the hospital with a bill I
can't afford or like in fact the person
I live with who maybe is that risk so
I'm sorry Zach and I wanna I want to
hear updates but the next got moved on
to the next emails for me oh yeah Jason
Jason says hey wisecrack I wanted to
write in about the most recent episode
of culture binge and share my tips for
how to stay sane during kovat nineteen
corners like many wise crack listeners
I'm a big movie fan but I have quite a
few gaps in my cinematic knowledge
spanning both the classics and more
recent films that have won awards or
just been well reviewed I figured there
were I figured there will likely be no
better time to dive into the hours upon
hours of films I've been putting off
watching and so far I've been able to
stay positive and optimistic through
quarantine because of it my advice to
anyone like me who wants to become
better versed in some classic films the
Turner Classic Movies channel for anyone
who still has a cable subscription has
proven to be a goldmine of movie
catalogs so far the highlights have been
Doctor Zhivago Gaslight and network
network is a favorite noaina and
Jarrett's possibly the two of you about
sure and I'm looking forward to starting
an Akira Kurosawa binge I hope everyone
is able to stay healthy sane and happy
through the respective quarantine binge
on Jason that's awesome and I think he's
setting a good example it's so easy to
watch dumb stuff right now but balance
it out with some classics rewatch some
stuff that you think sounds good look up
some movie list on some great websites
and stuff like that
see what people a wisecrack like etc any
more emails or is that it for today uh
we have one more oh great this is from
one again March 27th well I don't know
what is emailing us from Malaga Spain
I'm sorry if I pronounced that wrong I
should know better
but anyway March 27th don't know how
things have changed in Spain since then
hey guys wanna hear that kovat thing has
been pretty rough here we've been in
quarantine for over two weeks now
probably four by the time the next
episode of the podcast comes out and we
are not allowed to leave the house
unless we can prove that we are going to
work or to buy groceries because there
are policemen everywhere god damn
anyway I wanted to share the few things
I've discovered that keep me sane during
this awful time number one is just dance
YouTube videos dancing as if it were
playing is a great way to do a little
bit of exercise my family and laugh
together I think sir we talked about
that to having what I call a culture
journal it's just a notebook where I
write every book I read in every series
movie I watch I also try to summarize
the message that I feel conveys hey
helps making me feel like I'm not
consuming content mindlessly just to
pass the time [ __ ] that's so cool
yeah Wow I I think we could all learn
from one does he have more yeah well
just sorry one more realizing the third
is realizing that I cannot be as
productive as when I could leave for a
walk or someone's my mental health has
improved since I stopped trying to study
six hours every day attending online
class and and attending online classes
that's all just want to thank you guys
all three of you are beautiful thank you
on well I think Juan's third point
especially the first we read we should
all do those things that sounds great
but his third point about realizing that
he can't be as productive I would you
say that's the most clutch thing for
everyone to realize right now this like
weird thing that happened the first
couple weeks here was like I'm gonna I
wanna read my screenplay
I'm gonna do my thing right now like no
we're facing a global pandemic we all
have a lot of stuff we're dealing with
in terms of how we're feeling and I
think it's totally okay to be kind to
yourself and not have that much
expectation so everyone be like one I
think we could can we say that that
comfortable that until we find out that
one is like or breathe Tigers one Wan
could be a tiger breeding murderer and I
would still want to be like him so you
know be like WAN and also be like the
people that rate and review this podcast
be like the people that call us at 1 2 1
3 5 3 4 8 8 0 7 be like the people that
email is a culture of into a wisecrack
oh we know this is gonna continue to be
a weird time and we want to hear how
you're doing we want to hear what you're
doing want to hear what sort of culture
you're consuming we want to hear if
there's anything you would like to hear
us talk about so please bug us let us
know we're here to serve you we are the
heroes of we're not the heroes but we
listen to everything so you write an
email we do read it it comes directly to
my personal inbox
yes and also I'm breeding Tigers so
before we get going
Alec is
Tiger King mine are all in tiny cages
under a couch they're not allowed to see
sunlight but if people you know we're
only around every couple weeks or for
our British listeners fortnightly so in
the intervening time serving Alec where
can people find you
sri patel 22 on twitter wise doc alec
also on twitter at michael o burns also
screen would look at that we do we put
on the screen and like I always say just
DM me on Twitter and I'll give you my
address if you just want to come over
and hang out that's don't do that I
don't know I probably do it though
because I get reckless on the internet
but thank you so much everyone for
listening and watching Alec and sir be
thank you to you and delightful as
always and thank you to me listen you
got to learn to love yourself sometime
this is Ben culture binge we'll be back
soon come back in two weeks and see us
then thank you and goodbye
[Music]